welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your captain definition were almost at
the final frontier with a penultimate
episode of Picard now being released our
mission is to boldly go where no one has
gone before and give our thoughts on the
new entry as well as what could be
happening in the future things are
slowly starting to come together and
this episode really narrows down the
plot and has a couple of cool moments in
it that I definitely think are worth
talking about the episodes had went to
hour-long entries recently but this one
drops back to 45 minutes for a slightly
tighter entry throughout this video
we'll be discussing the ins and outs of
the ninth episodes plot it's Easter eggs
and what we thought of it as a whole we
will be engaging with heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
catch the show yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now at the end of the
video I'm also gonna be talking about
the big plot point that was potentially
leap from the script but I'll give you a
heads up before we get to that just in
case you don't want it ruined anyway
with all out the way thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of Picard episode 9
okay so episode 9 is the first episode
in the series that doesn't open with the
the a dream or a flashback it picks up
immediately after last week with the
crew of La Serena arriving at their
destination in the who Leone system as
we know the Romulans decided to take
their time getting there so the crew
have arrived a capitalist far far
earlier narak shows up not long after
and we saw last week that he'd been
waiting for them and then we finally get
it here the red alert sound from TNG
which screams throughout the ship I
think that this is the first time it's
been in the series and it's a nice
little callback even if they don't say
shields up
Red Alert I can't do the voice anyway
there's a quick little space battle and
after the young Hobbit pulls some nice
maneuvers we get the first big moment in
the episode when the Borg cube arrives
since being regenerated by 7m9 the ship
is now able to bring its weapons back
online and as we know that cube is a
floating Armada it does get pretty
messed up in the episode but I think it
will be a big player in next week's
entry the planet sends its defenses to
tackle the three vessels and after Rafi
states that they look like orchids Shoji
says that she sure they just call them
orchids which does show that she has
been to the planet before and is aware
of their countermeasures she later says
that she has a small grasp of the planet
but is unable to fully remember
specifics stating that she and maddux
must have left it when she was very
young
this is similar to the story last week
in which we learned that arias had come
face-to-face with the synth named Janna
out in deep space Rios's captain was
ordered to kill her by Commodore oh and
from this episode we can gather that
Mattox became aware of this and this is
why Sochi and dodge were instead just
dropped on different planets and neither
reached out to Starfleet everything
comes crashing down into the atmosphere
burning up the flowers and it sends
Picard into a state of losing his
surroundings in picard episode 2 we
learned that he was suffering from
aromatic syndrome a dementia-like
disease that was going to severely limit
his lifespan so far he's avoided the
worst of it but as the season is coming
to a close
it's slowly catching up with him the
ship's power shuts down meaning that
they're unable to use the medical bay
automatically luckily there's doctor on
board he
if she's a homicidal maniac Agnes says
that she managed to revive Ricard using
the older technology of a trike or tear
this symbolically shows that the Li old
and seemingly redundant methods are
often cast aside they are still more
useful in some ways than their apparent
new and improved replacements of course
this metaphorically has ties to Picard
it was pretty much cast to the side
after his resignation however throughout
the series he has shown that it can
still keep up with the best of them
let's face it the old ways are a lot
better because I'd rather hang around
with Riker and try for 45 minutes than
these suckers just kid Magnus I love you
but not really the aesthetic is later
picked up upon when they eventually
reached solji's home and because
wrinkles are able to tell stories they
imply what he's been through and
survived and are not something to be
embarrassed or ashamed of and I did
appreciate this theme being laced
throughout the episode Agnes has an
earth Picard's disease but there's no
time to rest as like him the ship needs
to be put back together
Picard calmly tells them that he's gonna
drop Shoji off with the people and then
says that they need to prepare for a
fight as if the big ball cube that's
just smashed in that planet wasn't big
enough to tell them but nevermind he
also opens up about his disease but
states that everyone who treats him like
an old man is gonna get sent to the
torpedo Bay and blasted off into space
it's a really emotional moment and I
don't know if it's because I've been
through similar things with members of
my family who for whatever reason didn't
want to be a burden but this kind of got
to me
pride can often make people think that
the second they need help is the moment
that they become useless
I think Picard as a whole has very much
been about the character proving these
perceptions wrong
Picard decides that because time isn't
running short enough what with his
disease shutting down his body bit by
bit and the incoming war fleet that they
should head to the ball cube to look for
human l know he's in for a surprise
because Hugh has of course died but I'm
happy they found a way to get seven of
nine back with Picard even if it's very
brief they reactivate the cube and use
the long-range scanners onboard here
they pick up the incoming Romulan
warbirds and count their numbers at 218
the group set back out and Eleanor
decides to remain behind on the cube I
don't know why this guy even came along
he's pretty much only beaten the show to
drop in on the board cube and get 79
there but I suppose he did defend Hugh
ever mind anyway the group arrived at
the compound and we can see that it's
full of twins as we know androids tend
to be made in pairs and it seems that
they have found a way to meld machine
and organic on a mass scale so G is
finally home and not only is she
recognized but also Picard is for being
data's captain we learned that the fleet
are two days away and then they need to
make all kids but a big moment comes
when dr. Alton indigo soon makes an
appearance played by Brett Spiner
we learned that in some ways he is
data's brother dr. Soong who created
data is actually his father and no they
aren't blood relatives they're pretty
similar appearance-wise
now is this guy a synth yeah potentially
I think it could be I can see it being a
cool twist that may be revealed in
either episode 10 or in the next season
or he could just be a normal guy I'll
leave that up to you in the comments now
what I do think this does is that it
shuts down the theories that data would
be returning through before before did
appear in episode 1 and this led to fans
speculating that he would be coming back
as a fully fledged character however
those theories were quickly debunked and
brent Spiner also publicly said that
it's getting more and more difficult to
play an ageless Android this however
brings the actor back in an interesting
way that allows him to go out for beers
on a Friday night
we have been wondering for a while now
who exactly was behind everything
involved in the creation of dodge in
Sochi and now we know for sure that soon
continued his father's work another
version of Sochi arrives called Sutra
who he learned was the sister of Janna
we learned that the secret of the jack
bash may actually be intended solely for
synthetic minds and that the madness
which comes from it is through organics
trying to comprehend it this is why
those Romulans went mad and it's
actually a nice little twist that I
didn't see coming through Agnes's mind
all kamasutra twists our way into our
memories and discovers the truth because
organic life is born out of chaos and is
ultimately finite our nature is to
strive for perfection and thus all life
will create synthetics once it hits a
certain point however organic life will
ultimate
we come to hate this out of either
jealousy or bitterness and they will try
and destroy it in doing so they will
destroy themselves and thus a higher
level of since weights on the outskirts
of the universe watching over all and
waiting for their time to be called
forth Sutra wishes to tackle his head on
whereas Shoji wants to find an
alternative where so many don't have to
die Sutra sort of takes on a villainous
role as the episode progresses and it's
clear that she wants a reason to wipe
out the organics for what they've done
to her kind you could say that Sutra
represents the Karma for organics a Kama
Sutra I've already done that joke I'm a
terrible terrible journalist
anyway zoom has been creating a body
that could have a mind transfer put into
it and thus the person would gain
immortality soon wishes to use it for
himself due to the fact that he's
getting old but I do find it unlikely
that it's gonna be him who ends up in it
my theory is that Picard gets
transferred into this as I can't really
see who else is going to be an
applicable candidate for it especially
especially with him being at death's
door and CBS likely wanting a second
season narak is brought to the base and
we get to meet Spock - don't know why
they needed a number for the cat cuz we
didn't give one to our cat Madonna which
was named after yeah it was it was my
mother's card I didn't name it well you
can draw the line sir Raffy tells Picard
that she loves him and he almost Peyser
but he says it back it feels like a
final goodbye and they do mention in the
episode that every time a goodbye is
said between two people that it could be
their last which I took this moment as
meaning Picard reaches back out to
Starfleet and Eric's it's dehydrated in
itself he and so do you break up with
one another and Eric says that he's
genuinely sorry for what's happened we
have been theorizing for a while that he
will end up switching sides and I
definitely think that this is cemented
by this conversation narak spots a
brooch of a hummingbird that is later
uses a knife to stab a synth and this is
able to escape with Sutras help so Jim
Picard talk about the logic of sacrifice
and how sometimes life must be ended in
order to protect life it's a nice little
conversation and the episode really
ramps up is Sutra goes to setting Eric
free she clearly allows this to happen
in order to show that organics are bad
and now we don't know for definite it is
likely that she brain there
the murder similar to how there was a
false flag attack with the sins on Mars
to outlaw them Sutra is showing that
organics are bad by following a similar
sort of methodology and making fear
drive the need for revenge so ji did pay
lip service to fear being the main
motivator in murder and it is cemented
here by sutras actions now it is
possible that Sutra is actually the
destroyer as she wishes to annihilate
organic life by the sounds of it she
could also end up becoming the fifth and
final ball queen in the series as the
cube is now on the planet and it is
possible that the character could end up
heading there this is your first time
checking out the video then just so you
know every week we talk about how data
had five Queen cards in the opening of
the show and this pointed to there being
five queens in the series so far there's
been Gianna Dodge Sochi seven of nine
and now it looks like Sutra is taking up
the position Suman Sutra have created a
beacon to summon the since on the
outskirts of the universe and they will
likely come forth and wipe out all
organics this is really ramping up for
war and it's a very tense way to end the
episode with Sutra as sort of becoming
someone who rallies the troops together
there's very much a persecution motif
that is similar to the Jews in world war
ii and picard says that he wishes to
hide the sins whilst the government
searches for them and that he will argue
with Starfleet that they're good he says
that the Federation will listen to him
but as we know they don't really care
about his opinion and thus this
suggestion falls on deaf ears soon in
the sins place him under house arrest
and agnes states that she will side with
the robots but as we know from a nature
she's probably gonna stab him in the
back
ruin their plans and the show in general
I'm just kidding Agnes I'm sorry I love
you the episode ends with this cutting
to comodoro leading the fleet of
Romulans as they approached the planet
now going forward Picard is clearly
trying to convince LG to rethink a
course of action as predicted naraku's
switch sides with him no longer being
selfish he will likely be what brings us
down Sutras plans after the sins
discover it was her who let him out it
looks like there's gonna be a big
faceoff and I really enjoyed this
episode and can't wait to see what
happens in the finale now for the rest
of the video we will be going into the
plot leaks so if you want to duck out
now thanks for making it to this point
it's not a show ruining reveal but
I spoil something cool so this is your
last chance to back out
you're still here thank you and the
league that dropped recently from
Twitter user angry mr. feeble and
allegedly showed a page from the script
in which Picard Rafi and Agnes say their
goodbyes to Rios you can pause the video
and read the patrons screen if you want
but basically it has Agnes Tseng
Torrio's that they should move away with
each other to Osaka in it Agnes
professors that I love too Rios who
completely rebuffs everything she says
that he got her to open up and that she
hasn't felt this way in a long time Rios
tries to interrupt her saying that he
can't but she doesn't want to go on
without him
Rio says that he needs to show us
something and then he says to the ship
disable emergency command hologram upon
saying this Rios begins to fade away
showing that he was a hologram this
entire time now whether this is true or
not we won't know till next week but
personally I think it contradicts a lot
of things in the show basically in this
episode Rios opened the shutters on the
ship so I don't know how he could do
this if he was a hologram and secondly
when he went to canto bytes so sorry I
mean the las vegas planet he was served
personal ads which would only be the
case if he was a person where this leak
could indeed be true and does at least
look like it's been professionally done
i guess we'll see next week I do
actually
I do actually quite like the twist
anyway that that's for the that's the
leaks part of the video over with now
obviously I'd loved hear your thoughts
on Picard so comment below and let me
know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and if you
missed any of our breakdowns on the
episode so far then they're gonna be
linked in a playlist at the end you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate it Lister thank
you you get access to content early you
want to come chat to us after the show
either follow us at definition whitey
will click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definitions thanks again
for taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]